junkies movie fights what in the world
it's movie fights what's going on
everybody Wow
today's show features two competitors
you each these two gentlemen have are a
treasure trove a king's ransom and it's
an embarrassment of riches of movie
knowledge as our four spiders this guy
oh you know I'm gonna love him from the
screen junkies and sometimes that chair
right there yes he's often sitting in
that chair he's a jack of all trades
he's the professor Juan Harris what's up
brother hey what's up al thanks for
having me Oh a pleasure what did they
like to move from over there to over
here yeah what's what's going on with
you what's the last movie you saw what
is the last movie I saw in theaters it
was anihilation okay I've seen a few
other caught up with a few other things
I got a rewatch the movie that we're
gonna be debating today because I
realized I don't remember very well
gotcha no spoilers um and they're it's
too late to rewatch it before the
argument and anything you want to plug
no no I'm good follow me on Twitter at
L&S and watch me on all sorts of screen
jockey shows thank you sir oh and this
gentleman he's an esteemed film critic
he crushes it in the Schmo down and he's
an all-around swell guy welcome William
Viviani Bibbs thank you very much thank
you very much to be back yeah yeah yeah
it's been a while I am excited I'm
excited to fight movie wise because I'm
useless in any other kind of fight oh
great I mean III think most of us who do
this kind of thing yeah I if I was
challenging any other kind of fight I
would run away to my mom we tried once
didn't work out oh I like that a food
ago I could launch pudding at
someone oh yeah it was only fashion
beauty copies a food fight but that's
the hurt with DVDs of food fight best
movie food fight of all time Oh Animal
House right the Bratz movie guys come on
the whole school snowball fight so does
it snowball fight in the cafeteria where
they bring in the snowballs say
snowballs get your red-hot snowballs and
I always thought that was funny because
that gold um thank you for that
reference Wow
we are gonna go down the rabbit hole
today folks
bibs thank you so much for being here
very much and you guys know how the show
works there are three votes going into
each deciding round my vote and the
Dan's let's go to the damn cam Dan Merle
how's it going brother
oh the answer to that question is Ernest
goes to camp I'm good how you doing I'm
glad to be back I wasn't here last week
and happy to be back with the screen
junkies with my fellow Dan here on the
fact checking camera hell yeah always
good to have your steady hand on the
facts and well where would we be without
the delightful the fabulous Danielle
Radford so those of you I think most of
you kind of know how this works but I
will break down how I help with the
judgment of the things yes please um so
I speak for you I am the voice of the
people
however our voice only counts if there's
a tie but we will still talk about what
we voted for you still matter I love you
the votes only happened on YouTube there
are some unofficial Twitter polls they
are fun they do not count the only poll
that counts is on YouTube and the
YouTube poll does not go live until both
fighters have answered the question we
don't want people prematurely voting
before they've actually started to hear
the arguments that's not fair it's kind
of mean what do you want to do is go to
the right hand side of your YouTube
screen hit the iCard and you will see
the poll if the poll isn't showing up
for you what you want to do is go down
then to the lower right hand side hit
the gear turn annotations on and off
that will make it so the iCard will
appear and then you can vote in the poll
I love you I know that was a lot of
information will continue to tell you
throughout the thing we love you bye
it's easy thanks Danielle and do not
forget to send to send Danielle corgis
and some sick memes some dank memes both
sick and dank memes on the spectrum
Italia SiC and egg all right so before
we crack open the bad
let's go back to mr. dan Merle he's got
a very special announcement for us dan
what's going on yeah what you know just
some movie fights business that we
wanted to settle and this has been
something that we collectively have been
discussing for quite a while obviously
when we came back last year we used that
as an opportunity to fix a lot of things
some things are still in the process of
fixing one of them being this show there
were some things that we thought could
be improved one one of them was the
format we saw a lot of opportunities
with the two fighter format you know
particularly yes and no 5050 questions
that we thought it would work well you
know going from three fighters to two
fighters and as with any period of
adjustment we knew that there would be
some voices saying hey you know I liked
it the way that it was we were prepared
for that and you know there were reasons
that we did that that are so many
reasons that we do I would I'd put some
of them out there on Twitter but you
know we just felt like we needed a
change and you know I think we're all in
agreement and I think that a lot of the
viewers are in agreement the a lot of
the changes on the show have worked the
new judging I think fewer rounds has
made the show a little more streamlined
a little shorter and I think those are
positive changes but one thing that we
obviously heard the most about was the
change in format and I know a lot of you
don't like the two fighter format it's a
format that we wanted to try out because
we just felt that it was an interesting
way to take the show we do hear you
though when you say that you don't like
things and I think a lot of people
thought that we weren't listening or
that we were ignoring you and initially
I think there's some frustration from a
lot of us because we thought you know we
were a little frustrated I didn't see
how people were gonna give him a chance
and that's all we wanted to do is to
give this format a chance taking risks
is kind of hard yeah
so we committed to giving this two
fighter format a shot we really wanted
to tweak it and do the best that we
could with it however you know we do
listen to what our fans say and what you
guys say and even amongst a lot of our
kind of you know we have we see names
that pop up a lot and we take
everybody's feedback into account but
even amongst some of the most hardcore
fans I think still with
this format they're like you know I'm
adjusting to it I like it but it also
became very clear was that there was
something about the three fighter format
the previous format that gave the show a
quality that for a while our viewers
just wasn't there anything just some
extra oomph there was something that you
both felt was missing see it's something
that this that the new format just
didn't quite capture so we sat down we
talked about it we discussed all of our
options do we keep doing it do we not do
the show anymore you know or do we go
back to the old way of doing it and I
think that we decided that what we want
to do more than anything and what we
said when we started was that we want to
come back bigger and better than we were
and we want this show to be bigger and
better than it was and so we made the
decision that we are going to go back to
the three fighter format we think that
we can incorporate a lot of the positive
changes the judging will stay the same
Daniele and I will still be here we'll
still be taking the fan poll how will
still be the host we're still gonna have
you know the three right now the three
rounds there are gonna be fewer rounds
the things that we like we're gonna keep
we're gonna keep the show streamlined we
want to keep you involved with your
voice at home but we are gonna go back
to the three fighter format because we
want we want people to like the show we
want people to engage in the show and we
don't want to tired you don't want to
take anything away from this show that
people love Riya seemed like there was
something about that format that people
loved in the chairs
[Applause]
it's going down ooh sweet IKEA
sponsorship yeah but more than anything
we didn't want the continued debate
about the format to showed of the show
to overshadow the fact that we just want
to put on a really fun and really
entertaining and a really good show for
you guys at home so the way that's gonna
work is we're gonna do today's show like
normal we're gonna be dark next week
because we have to reset the stage again
they're the podiums are gonna go out we
have to redo the lighting we have to
bring in you know a place for people to
sit we have to kind of reset a bunch of
stuff so we're not gonna be here next
week buddies podiums have a future as
firewood firewood call it like a heroes
ending yes if you like if you want to
get your movie fights its scratch next
week and you're here in LA we are gonna
be at WonderCon yeah so we're gonna do a
wide movie fight at WonderCon with a lot
of your fan favorites and and I can
announce this we usually say that we're
gonna premiere an honest trailer a
surprise honest trailer for the audience
I will actually tell you which honest
trailer we'll be premiering at WonderCon
next week will be the honest trailer for
Star Wars the last Jedi whoa what you
might want to check out so not a
divisive movie for now we're just gonna
let it go no movie fights live next week
we'll be real beginning things prepped
for our return we will be back in two
weeks we'll be back with three fighters
we want this show to be great we want
everyone to have a great time watching
it we want to have a great time making
it so that's it thank you for killing
this format
once this place saw happen there was no
more yes Dan thank you so much for
breaking that down eloquently and
succinctly and yeah I echo everything
and Wow exciting breaking news look
forward to all that and hell yeah I'll
be at WonderCon a lot of people right
here will be at WonderCon so come and
check us out there and without further
ado JT e dropped that sick ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow okay jte best package in the biz
let's kick it off with question number
one gentlemen you ready all right now
thank you so we got our first look at
fantastic beats fantastic piece yeah
starring dr. Dre fantastic beats tastic
for your liver so we got our first look
at fantastic beasts their crimes of
Grindelwald this week so we want to know
is the fantastic beasts franchise a good
or a bad idea is it a good or a bad idea
and we're gonna start with the man to my
left lawn Harris that's me
well long story short bad this is a bad
idea for a way to fall the Harry Potter
franchise what a rich franchise so much
to explore so many characters you could
spin off such a rich sense of
world-building and location and what
they've decided to do is make a prequel
that said so far in the history before
any of those events happen and so far
away in terms of the context in terms of
the location that it's basically
unrecognizable as part of the Harry
Potter world and franchise it it's a
franchise with magic in it but that
doesn't really connect to the original
stories and doesn't even give itself
chances to connect because only the
oldest characters in the Harry Potter
world or even alive at the time that
we're taking they were set in these
stories you can do a different era in
the same location for a prequel you
could do a different location or you can
you could take one of those two but you
can't do a different era and a different
location because now we have no context
unless you read Potter more every day
you don't have a good grounding on
what's even happening in this world one
other point I want to make about this
franchise before I yield Viviani there's
two threads going on right now in these
stories you've got Newt Scamander his
suitcase full of crazy animals they keep
getting loose he's making friends in New
York even though he's on his way
somewhere else he's switching suitcases
with a guy that's your one-story then
you've got this totally other story
about Dumbledore and his old friend
Grindelwald in his very familiar plan
to get rid of mud Bloods and make
wizards all purebloods and that story
really doesn't other than pure
coincidence doesn't even connect to our
main Newt Scamander story you're all
over the place instead of the Potter
films which are so organized or so lean
the storytelling is so tight everything
is there for a reason and now we've
given way to this really scatter shot
hard to pin down confusing over
complicated and just not fun series
that's barely even recognizable as Harry
Potter Wow a passionate opening salvo
from lawn Harris bibs of course it's a
good idea my god how can you say it's a
bad idea I understand maybe you don't
like one film more than another of
course but it's a great idea one of the
most appealing things about Harry Potter
from the beginning was JK Rowling's
world building and this is a rich
fantasy universe with a great history
every single piece of it every book
every character has an extended history
much like in Star Wars I like in Star
Wars you can tell stories from different
eras of it this is the Knights of the
Old Republic of Harry Potter and if that
doesn't sound exciting to you you do not
like everybody very much because Harry
Potter is a thrilling world in which we
all want to live that is why all the the
the new theme park attractions are so
exciting right now people want to go
there people want to live there and
limiting it to just Harry Potter and
saying it could only be Harry Potter is
really a crying shame and there's so
many other opportunities for exciting
stories new characters and new locations
to say otherwise I think is a crisis of
imagination and I pity you I pity you I
pity you and I pity you sir Wow slug it
out fella
I'll say your case you're making is the
case I'm making there are JK Rowling did
a great job of world-building the Harry
Potter universe there's lots of
opportunities for great exciting stories
so why are we stuck worrying about the
intricacies of magcon USA and we're not
even gonna be there the next movies
going to Paris so we spent all this time
setting up magic in the turn of the
century in New York for no reason
because you want to explore the entire
world explore America we're gonna
explore France are gonna explore
everywhere but what is really exploring
it was going man
not knowing anything go there we're
going we're having a context-free
adventure where we don't understand
anything that we're seeing unless we
read all the supplemental materials
removing pay attention you brought up
Star Wars these are two franchises the
people complain have the same problem
there's all these books there's all
these comics so this backstory that you
suspected to read Star Wars I think does
a slightly better job than Harry Potter
it at least bringing you along filling
you in in the movies Harry Potter is
just stranding you in these locations
getting you very little background and
then be like alright now what are you
insane it's full it's without anything
interesting or specific a fantastic
piece is an incredibly interesting story
I don't think David Yates threats and
very durable I think he's a very I think
he's a rather inert director but that's
the movies fault it's not the ideas well
there's one of you brought up that I
want to bring out movie is bad you can't
say the idea is bad because I think even
your agreeing is a good idea
arguing we're not arguing is more Harry
Potter good idea we're arguing is this
franchise if you is a guy wandering
around with a briefcase full of magical
animals but that's not even the point of
the franchise isn't it a good it's not
the point of the franchise is we're
older more préval de mort wants to do
the exact same thing Voldemort did you
exactly what's the franchise about you
want to say the same thing about the
original Harry Potter fans is this a
story about a kid growing up in a
magical school here's a story about a
looming war that's happening in the
background wait what kind of a looming
war because a guy wants to kill the kid
who's going to school is a pretty flat
school it's always a story with a subway
we have a story of a newt senator who is
a mr. nasty Cyclops these are his two
plots that don't mesh together all going
on at the same time located for you are
going on at the same time they are that
great they don't know that's not
greatness how do you tell stories listen
this is the kind of story that I
actually know Lee it's about a bunch of
parallel stories they come together if
the only reason these stories happened
together is because one guy grabs the
wrong suitcase that's the only
connection siding that's all the story
no real reason that Newt Scamander has
to be the guy fighting a great
that is stupid chose one it's that
there's no reason we have a bear that's
how a lot of stories begin three days of
the gala right a guy who just happened
to be there it's still a great story so
far it's two stories that don't link up
and it's a story led by a guy that
doesn't have anything to do with the
stories but it doesn't matter who cares
9si you didn't listen to me and you
didn't listen to the movie that's your
argument right now I didn't pay
attention I don't care this isn't what I
like more there's no telling what I
literally told you a whole bunch of
stuff and you decided to look at only
the surface element I'm saying you've
told me that they're two parallel
sweeties don't really know he's telling
me what my argument is rather than
actually argue my actual Zira win you
want you won't say anything it's a lot
easier to win to be fair line you're not
letting him say anything you have about
this franchise but okay what do you what
do you want to say um I want you to
break down what you think he's missing
about your argument well first off I
think you're missing the fact that
actually there's a really great story at
the heart of this first off Newt
Scamander is a really fantastic
protagonist I loved having an introvert
at the center of an action oriented
franchise we never get that almost all
stories about introverts are about
people who need to shop I see you
leaning not that he is he is a very
interesting character the kind we never
see before he'd usually be the sidekick
and you had to come out of his shell
this is the kind of aspirational
character I think a lot of people never
get to see in an action story so hey I
love that I love his character so stop
talking trash about his character I
think his character is really really
into Harry Potter's an introvert yells
at that guy you know he's confused he
comes into his bullying happy no stories
the story of the Harry Potter friend
that's the story of that guy this is
story about a different care to see
different characters have different
stories line I don't know if you know
that so we have that history is he comes
into America he immigrated to America
it's a story about customs going wrong
and here's this fascinating you're right
yes he's gone to America we're dealing
with American issues we're dealing with
American xenophobia American racism he
comes to America and they explore
various concepts that are parallel with
magical stories in an American context
we were seeing the American Harry Potter
story or the American story said in the
Harry Potter verse and I think a very
rich way that actually covers a lot of
the various bases and now we get to see
that in another country every single
time the idea for that is rock-solid you
are arguing maybe the implementation is
failing you you are not arguing that the
idea is bad you are arguing that you
don't like that it is not Harry Potter
you don't like that they're doing a
different kind of story the idea for
this story is sound it's a good idea for
a franchise and people are actually
heard ringing it's making a lot of money
it's doing rather well from a financial
perspective it's making more money than
most of the DC EU films so this is
actually working out great do I have
cripples with it yeah I don't think
David Gates is a great director but I
think from a story perspective this is
really interesting and I'm glad we have
it great thank you for laying that out
for Spivs lon oh yeah that's right but
does it really because I get a but
here's a respond what we got is a
delightful run of vague generalities oh
it's Harry Potter in America so we deal
with race and we deal with American
history we do it the Wild West and the
railroads none of that is in the movie
okay all right well he let you speak I
apologize you know just very much
reminds me of my mom and dad at the
dinner table of this movie is a weird
romance between the side characters
Queenie Jacob are they gonna make it
work or not that's what a lot of our
time is spent on a lot of her time is
also spent on Tina Goldstein and what's
going on in her Mac us a magical
Congress of America we've got all these
busyness going on
we don't really ever get to the core of
anything observational about America or
the American character its totally
ludicrous it's just America cuz that's a
different place to go I still maintain
nothing that you said in that
long-winded diatribe that I was not
allowed to speak during none of that
actually spoke to what I was saying was
the big problems with this franchise in
his defense you're also getting a
long-winded diatribe you are that he's
not allowed to speak during I love him
I live for a diatribe which is still
that if these stories don't link up a
noose commanders not really the
protagonists of this story in a
meaningful way he's he's there he's a
witness to it he sort of seemingly
getting involved dragged in at times I'm
him the new trailer it looks to be much
the same
this is Dumbledore's fight against
Dumbledore his old foe and he's bringing
Newt Scamander the guy with the suitcase
in and these things are not linking up
in a real or satisfying way I want to do
I know that we're going way way on here
I do want to go one more one more thing
I want to bring out yes are we are in
final this is my final argument no bring
it up we're nearing the end say what
you're gonna say I was gonna say we
basically we have Grindelwald and
Voldemort and these are not meaningful
different characters in an interesting
way these are characters with the same
motivation basically the same style of
operating their shadowy and in secret
they're slowly coming back they're
aligning evil wizards along with them
even we've got leaderless strange
instead of Bellatrix Lestrange wouldn't
it have been more interesting to explore
a different kind of evil in this world a
different kind of foe for them to fight
rather than basically recreating the
last few Potter films the next movie
without having seen it which I do not
care for at all that's a trailer they
think the fans characters that's not
necessarily the concept of it you didn't
like the first film I get that I didn't
like Moonraker but I didn't think they
should cancel James Bond I think this is
actually a good idea for a franchise I
think there's a great structural setup I
think Newt Scamander is a great
character and yeah you're right he kind
of falls into a lot of these storylines
so did Harry Potter he just went to
school and crap happened to him that was
interesting and that was exciting
there's no reason why we have to judge
Newt Scamander on a totally different
standard than we judged Harry Potter
good freeze so one final thing I want
you to take 30 seconds lon look into
that camera that camera is a child who
loves Harry Potter tell him why you
think we know more Harry Potter listen
listen my son you're gonna hear a lot of
people on this stage say that what I'm
arguing is that we shouldn't have any
more Harry Potter movies but that's not
what this question was as you understand
because you're a reader I understand
what the question was was he
this a good idea for a Harry Potter
series and I'm saying no and in fact mr.
Viviani William over here
you heard him previously say that this
series is like Knights of the Old
Republic for Harry Potter but that's the
founding of Hogwarts Godric Gryffindor
that's the Old Republic this is some
minor period in 100 years earlier
history thank you Wow amazing
William your camera is a jaded redditor
who does not want to see anything Harry
Potter verse or fantastic Beats related
go ahead and tell them why there should
be I'm gonna I'm gonna quit the dance
here taking risks is hard you actually
need to give things a chance when
something comes along that isn't like
what you thought it was gonna be or
isn't the way you predicted it was going
to be sometimes the way you thought
things were gonna be that's just if
you're not gonna get that you got this
and you know what this is really
interesting and there's a lot of
potential for this we actually deserve
to give this a chance this deserves the
chance to grow to expand to become more
than Harry Potter first became when it
first started Harry Potter started as a
small story it became bigger this
started off as a news story or having
trouble giving a shot let's give it more
of an opportunity to grow because let's
be honest here JK Rowling gave us a
world we all want to live in and she
keeps giving us new chapters I'm excited
to see more aren't you time how long was
he you guys you know I can tell that you
know each other very well because it got
personal it you drop the gloves and went
to town on each other a slug restroom
old friends associates yes thank you for
the qualification okay we used to sell
discs we did they worked at a video
store together this is true so lon you
can you came out of the gates guns
blazing and I thought you had some I
mean it was only the first argument we
hadn't heard from Bibbs yet but you
already had him down on the match with
some near fatal blows just no connection
to the universe the the era was all out
of whack there was no context for the
characters but then bim's I really liked
your Star Wars comparisons and you
banded the harry potter story and in
talking about exploring the entire world
not just what we knew from the film and
you swayed we weighed me with that to a
degree and at the end of the day
listening to pipian ii i really started
to come over to his argument of it seems
like your problem is with the implement
the implementation of what's happening
here
you seem you said it yourself that you
want you're not opposed to more harry
potter and from what new biani says
we're not giving this the complete
chance it deserves and the question is
is the franchise a good or a bad idea
and you sold me with it being a good
idea and it might just be a problem with
the implementation in that respect so
I'm going point Bibby on e let's go to
Dan Merle hmm this is a this was very
close to very passionate arguments it's
kind of like unwinding a particularly
knotted rope at time unweaving whatever
one was saying yeah I I think the the
crux of the argument really was is it it
was more and and different and how these
two kind of interspersed lonna's kind of
saying like it's more but it's not any
different and maybe all he's saying you
know it's more and it's it's there's
more this it's in a good way this is
different these are different things i
introvert thing I felt went to Viviani
because I don't feel like they're the
same character I think there are
different characters I I think
ultimately while Juan was very
passionate i side with Viviani he sold
me on that the characters were different
enough that there were new avenues to
explore and and it's not a bad idea to
explore new facets of this universe why
didn't quite sell me enough on it being
the exact same thing and that we don't
need more so i think i also have to go
with bambi beyond he takes it but I
gotta hear from Danielle Radford what's
going on it has been
so close this fight that I'm literally
just refreshing it now so I can take a
look so right now we have got bad 50%
good 49% 1% is people who wanted more
beautiful creatures movies some of the
fun comments I knew some of these uh
some of these dank memes I got a lot of
wrestle gifts thanks rose a lot of
people mentioning that they would have
liked of beasts was closer to the Harry
Potter poke a mom they thought they were
gonna get babes you're that Wanda so
over people love it that's wrestling
talk it means that the crowd loves it
and then a couple of comments that I
really liked at pam-4 PA n th ro R wrote
having autism myself I could really
relate to Newt and he definitely was the
highlight of the movie for me
I liked that comment Harlequin 899 wrote
all the yelling of the three person
format with only two people road Raider
three fantastic bears beats Battlestar
Galactica and then agent three six four
nine six wrote I think I have to sing
this I'm bringing desk chairs back just
don't know how to so that's those are
our dankmemes
I'm bringing desk chairs back or that's
my desk in a box the result there was
one big factual thing that was brought
up which was building on his assertion
that fantastic piece is out earning most
of the film's in the DCU I'm gonna be
obi-wan Kenobi and say that that's true
from a certain point of view
[Laughter]
globally it is only been out learned by
a bag lady Superman and Wonder Woman
domestically it flip-flops and it's only
earned more than Justice League but
globally technically Viviani is correct
globally I think is why I count because
they're not gonna just give away that
money really didn't come from Batman V
Superman clarification thank you for
that and you know Harry Potter is a jock
how could it be that much of an
introvert he's the best of Quidditch
there is it was popular kid maad school
all right Viviani chosen one nil let see
question number two which will be better
which will be the better stand-alone DC
EU movie the flash or Aquaman
speak of the devil just talking about
the DC EU which will be better the flash
or Aquaman bibs we start with you okay
so obviously we're speculating a little
bit here because we haven't seen it but
we don't what is the potential to be to
better stand alone DC EU movies and only
one of these is actually a standalone DC
EU movie Aquaman is the story of Aquaman
we're gonna get to see him embroiled in
epic fights at the underwater battles as
my understanding there's gonna be a huge
war between you know the underwater
people of Atlantis and the surface
dwellers all of that is the kind of
story that can take place off to its
side just tell an Aquaman store we don't
need to deal with all the others
characters who might bring a lot of
baggage that we're not super interested
in flashpoint on the other hand is
literally not about the flash it is
about the flash going to an alternate
reality full of different versions of a
whole bunch of other characters I
believe they've already confirmed gal
gadot is going to be in the movie
this is not a story that's gonna be
about the flash it's a story about the
world this is a story about an alternate
reality this is a story that's going to
distract from the Flash's personal story
we haven't really had that much time
with him to begin with at least Aquaman
is gonna give Aquaman an opportunity to
grow to shine to take center stage flash
is gonna be literally running around the
entire city probably the whole world
meeting a whole bunch of different
superheroes probably circling all the
way back to Batman V Superman doing this
whole time travel shtick that is not a
standalone flash movie that is a
universe movie that is gonna probably
change and redefine the way we look at
the DC EU I'm interested but I'm not
interested in it as a story about the
flesh
blonde Harris I mean I think to start
off we got to just look at these two
characters as they currently exist in
the DC EU the flash we've got Ezra
Miller he's funny
we've got a pretty clear idea of who
Barry Allen is in this world and how
they're depicting the character with
Aquaman we've got a movie the only movie
we've seen him in is Justice League and
he is completely schizophrenic in that
movie who are we gonna get in this
standalone movie the aloof man of action
Eskimo Savior from the beginning the
cowboy Lobo riding on the backs of other
heroes saying woohoo from the end of the
movie neither of the characters are that
interesting but we're sort of locked in
to getting one or the other of them we
also have to think about this is going
to be a movie about betrayals among a
family of godlike kings in a fantasy
kingdom who occasionally go and interact
with earthquakes we've seen that it's
called Thor there's been three of them
we've sort of played all that out how
different is this really gonna be one
more thing about Aquaman we already got
a first scene introducing us to Aquaman
Atlantis mera his world in the middle of
Justice League
it was incoherent and made no sense that
it didn't make anyone excited to see
more about that Aquaman world that
they've been setting up it does not look
like a particularly inspired job of
setting it up over to flash the great a
lot of what William was saying actually
lines up to what I want to say it's
considered a standalone movie because
it's the flash so it's not a Justice
League movie it's not a Batman vs
Superman multiple characters teaming up
it's going to be the flash now he may go
to this flashpoint alternate dimension
that's what happens in the comic but it
would still be anchored we can presume
as a movie it's a flash movie they're
calling it the flash but the good thing
is we do already know the flesh we have
some background if you've been watching
the TV show Americans are pretty
familiar with the flash what his powers
are the very basic outlines of this
story so we don't need to do our next
interminable origin story we can just
hit the ground running no pun intended
and start off a flash movie in the
middle of the action with the flash
being the flash doing flash things using
the Speed Force going to an alternate
dimension
Aquaman flash clash okay there's so much
in what you just said but let's just
start right here okay you talk about
which Aquaman are we gonna see I see a
character with some actual layers how do
we know he's got layers because when he
was sitting on the lasso truth and
justice league we found out who he
really is we founded he's a character
who actually has doubts who actually is
a serious person who is fighting against
because right now he's immature I see
that as a potential for the character to
grow over the course of a story and is
that story going to involve kings and
conspiracies and Wars you bet you know
what other stories did that a hell of a
lot of Shakespeare this is the history
of the world this is the history of
kingdoms and empires and countries and
that is the grand stage in which this is
all set and to say that we've seen it
before is like saying oh I don't need to
see Game of Thrones I saw Richard the
third oh come on you know it's more
close than like just history
these are Kingdom's these are brothers
betraying each other it's gonna be very
similar to throw these comic books are
pretty similar like there's a lot of
similar ground for Thorin Aquaman to
cover okay listen
there that's true but that's true I like
a versatile Thor became over the course
of his stories we had an original story
that was Thor coming to earth luring him
the question is in Hell another man
become good by Aquaman three it's will
this bakla man movie that's coming out
soon be good and I'm saying but leading
in there it's not promise so they've got
to work let's look let's look at what
they had to work with ads work with one
scene this is what you're talking about
one thing we had in Atlantis injustice
about all the Aquaman stuff just like
that one scene is stands out as being
particularly bad but you talk about that
being sort of indicative of the Atlantis
that we're going to see listen James Wan
James Wan is directing aqua and James
why doesn't the most interesting and
exciting filmmakers we've got he'll he's
probably the modern master of horror and
his fast and furious movie was really
cool action I actually want to see what
he can do in a new environment we
haven't had like this kind of epic
underwater adventure movie ever but
James once talked publicly about how
difficult that's made how challenging
he's found it you should know how
difficult that's made the whole process
of making that noise ever Challen what a
flash doesn't have any of those kinds of
battle you know I have to try the water
productions historically of enemy
Waterworld stands out like that
complicates and on a soundstage from the
characters underwater that's why he's
talking about that's true but a but
James Cameron's doing the same thing
with the Avatar movies that doesn't
necessarily mean they're gonna suck
that's a totally different kind of
argument doesn't it avatars
[Music]
dunno there's a great track record of
directors who have a background in
comedy coming in and nailing these
movies Jon Favreau's done it the Russo
brothers have done it Joss Whedon's done
it and now John Francis daley and
Jonathan Goldstein who just did the
terrific game night are gonna get a
chance to come in here and do that
that's interesting a guy who's done all
horror movies and then one movie where
you came in to the seventh of a
franchise and it's not as good as the
two movies the pieces are bad that
franchise dealt a rough hand and six are
better than seven and I halfway through
the production it's a miracle that movie
works at all and give him a lot of
credit for that
so that's trouble production you said
right now it's gonna be complicated
production yeah the most complicated
blockbuster productions in modern memory
and made a good movie about it that
people like they made a ton of money and
it's and he said Oh coming into it Sam
Raimi was a horror director as well and
his spider-man movies changed the way
people know his first one was the first
modern superhero Bullock Buster
four-quadrant not just an action movie
about people and leather fighting bad
guys in the dark an actual movie with
real character development romance hit
everybody one can make a great movie and
I put faith in them
I've got a specific question for both of
you I want to know what will your film
add to the DC EU that we haven't seen or
how will it improve the DC EU let's
start with lon well my film is going to
really reinvent the DC you and a lot of
interesting ways we know that flashpoint
is a story where he goes to this
alternate dimension and can't sort of
mess with some of the reality there's
been a lot of rumor that DC is going to
use this as an opportunity to sort of
reinvent some of the characters or some
of the plot points that aren't quite
working but I mean either to go beyond
that and sort of the the major
retconning this is a chance for the DC
EU or DC films to explore it's the first
real opportunity we're gonna see in the
modern time to try like an elf's world
story to try a story that is sort of a
pivot off of the main universe that does
things that don't necessarily have to
always link up to the main chronology
because it is taking place in a
different dimension if this works much
like r-rated Deadpool this could
introduce
brand-new whole wing of comic book
movies where we take elaborate plot
lines that maybe don't link up to the
main story and we still get a chance to
explore them and I think that could be
really exciting right thanks lon William
the fact that lon had a great answer
that question means he should lose this
round because the point isn't how is
this going to affect the DCU the point
is how is it gonna be a standalone film
everything you're sitting about how
great the flash is gonna be is based on
plot it's based on new Elseworlds stuff
that actually is off on the side
digression what really counts here what
I think matters the most is how is it
gonna be about character Aquaman is not
gonna be a story about a whole bunch of
different characters a whole bunch of
different realities it's about one
reality in which he actually has to grow
as a character we're going to expand on
that carrot we're gonna learn more about
it land as much in the same way we learn
more about Lokhande and black panther
much the same way we'll learn more about
the world of magic and Doctor Strange of
the world of outer space and guardians
of the galaxy
I don't know everything they're gonna
add to the DC EU because it's actually
unexplored corner and that is way more
interesting than what if Batman was
someone else well listen that might be
would make a fun movie but that's not
actually gonna grow the universe not
just gonna say that ultimately a lot of
this stuff doesn't really matter
this is a side excursion this is the
flash going to another reality isn't
that fun great but that's plot and that
character this is the story about
character that's what a standalone movie
should be not about Oh what if the DCU
was something different any final
thoughts on yeah I mean I really didn't
understand a whole lot of that seemed
very contradictory you're sort of saying
on one level that it's good that it's
sort of a movie that's removed from the
main chronology because then we get to
dig in more to that character both of
our stories are removed from the main
chronology might takes place a bit
different dimension they could flash
would come back and it starts all over
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
universe changing thing and it is it's
flash going on an adventure
flash is going to this different
universe he's the one who's gonna have
to figure out how to get home and how to
set things right it is a flash adventure
so and I I just I really don't get it
clarify please because you do you want a
standalone movie that fits your final
thoughts right and I feel like we got
both arguments we got like here's why
you want it to be a standalone thing and
here's why you want it to be sort of
integrated with the with the world like
I think we're both kind of saying the
same thing mine's just no more
interesting so we haven't seen thank you
on well I'm final thoughts no my actual
argument is that yes they're both off on
their own little corner the difference
is that one is a corner that actually
exists and the other one is a corner
another reality which they can totally
just blink out of existence or worse say
that all the other stories can be
blanked out of existence that is a DC EU
movie that is not a standalone movie
that is not a story that is actually
about the character and the world that
is about a character leaving their world
a character we know less about than
Aquaman at this point because all we
really know is that he's neurotic and
that he's a new hero it's about him
going off somewhere running around
solving a bunch of problems that aren't
even all his problems it's just another
damn reality here we have Aquaman
actually in his environment in his
element literally water getting involved
with all the characters that he knows
there is way more potential for a
seriously dramatically interesting story
about Aquaman am I saying the flash part
will be a bad movie no actually they
might be a neat movie but is gonna be a
standalone movie by definition it is not
time
wow you guys came out of that guns
blazing Dan Merle yes what are your
thoughts well quickly it's just a couple
of facts factual Corrections technically
we saw Aquaman briefly and Batman to
grant so it wasn't the only DC movie
that he has appeared in so far also I
don't believe that
Aquaman said woo hoo and Justice League
is my man I would have accepted yeah it
might be there might be a woo hoo in
there he definitely says my man for me
again these two are great at arguing
each other like two sides of the same
coin yeah I think that it came stat so
many equal fights amongst equals it
comes down to punch and counter punched
in the eye the points that were brought
up I thought that line had really landed
a great punch with James Wan just kind
of referring to his history but then I
thought the Vianney punched back really
well saying that you know like first of
all Furious 7 of the challenges but that
movie at the Sam Raimi point I thought
was good and the fact the Sam Raimi was
known for this he came and did this he
made this great movie so like that was a
good punch in a counter punch secondly I
think that lon you know like he kind of
gave the non standalone thing but I
think line made some good points about
his movie going back so the thing that
really convinced me was the the point
about what's gonna have the best to say
about the character
for me I thought that Viviani made the
point about you saw something in Justice
League that showed you that this
character has room to grow and I think
that that was the more compelling
argument for me other than you know yes
there's a good team behind flashpoint
yes there are different things that they
can do but I thought the big Liana's
argument about the the places for the
character to grow hit stronger with me
so I'm gonna go with him and Aquaman in
this one Oh bibs so man this was a
furious battle yes fast and furious
James Wan I thought lon made some great
points about comedy directors
transitioning into directing these kinds
of films mentioned the Russo brothers at
all and but bibs you had some great
points as well and I thought there was a
real interesting debate regarding is
this a standalone movie what constitutes
a stand-alone film and exploring that
what's going on in Atlantis versus going
back in the DC EU and are we gonna use
it for just DC EU world building and
revisionist history or whatever you want
as fitting into the greater DC EU as
opposed to being a standalone film what
defines a standalone film but you both
man a back and forth a tete-a-tete
point-to-point on that and then lon had
an interesting point saying that we've
seen this before we've seen this story
before it's Thor but that's Marvel's
version and then I think bibs really
deflected that point by saying that's
like saying you can't have Game of
Thrones because we already have what was
your Richard the third King Richard the
third yeah so I thought that really
negated that point and at the end of the
day his argument for standalone film
taking it back to the question and I'm
not gonna say it was swayed by it but I
do like the point I do like the fact
they were holding the wand the entire
time
yeah I I have to give it to
Bibiana Daniel Radford William takes a
point but what's going on with the pole
all right well the poles in this one um
they're not as close as the ones the
last one we had aqua man with 62 the
flash with 37 and I just read a great
comment asking and I unfortunately
they're scrolling by so fast I couldn't
get your name sweetie but someone who
asked the question does Aquaman have a
cloaca and cloaca jokes are always gonna
work real big with the radford so here
are a couple of the comments that we had
Josh Peck 1098 wrote I'm gonna be the
third fighter in this fight I'm arguing
for the true standalone film that Martin
Scorsese produces and Todd Phillips
director film of the joker starring
Joaquin Phoenix is the Joker we also got
a lot of people who are really into
Aquaman a lot of folks are just like
straight up they are not accepting this
flash they are hardcore Grant Gustin all
day all day every day and you can't tell
them any differently but people did
really appreciate the James one argument
so very nice Thank You Danielle thank
you alright so it is - OH
Bibiana but it's still anybody's
ballgame and now let's move to round
number three in honor of tomb raider
what would be the worst video game to
turn into a movie an honor of tomb
raider what would be the worst video
game to turn to a movie and lawn we're
gonna start with you so I've chosen
Leisure Suit Larry there's ha there's
only two ways to go if you're gonna
adapt Leisure Suit Larry you're gonna
make a send-up of how out of step and
disgusting and inappropriate and awful
this game was or you're going to make a
faithful adaptation neither of these
things would be a good movie the parody
take on this old game would still be
just as scummy and unpleasant as the
game itself but now you'd have this
added layer of it also being preachy and
judgmental and going back and looking
and old mores and social mores and
sexual mores and the way that men and
women interacted and critiquing it I
don't really think anybody wants to
relive that and go through that even as
a satirical joke the other way to do it
would be just to do a straight
adaptation and make a movie about
Leisure Suit Larry which would be
absolutely atrocious will probably not
even get released in theaters it would
be like the I love you daddy
of 2018 I can't believe they made this
Leisure Suit Larry movie why would
anybody agree to be in Leisure Suit
Larry I don't know if you guys have
played this game it's nothing but pure
IEL sophomoric horrible sex jokes it's
extremely juvenile the entire point is
you're just trying to leave this
character to get laid and it's just
non-stop dumb jokes and massage me if it
was funny it might be sort of defensible
in some way sadly it is not thank you on
William we went in different directions
on this because you picked maybe the
most reprehensible video game ever made
I picked the most boring video game ever
made I'm talking about a little game
called desert bus you ever hear about
desert bus in desert bus a game for the
Sega CD you drive a bus the bus has no
people on it you drive from Tucson to
Las Vegas for eight hours
nothing happens except the bus lists
slightly to the right so you can't just
set your controller down and get the
point you will actually get fall off the
side of the road and you'll get towed
back to your original point of origin in
real time that is the most boring video
game anyone has ever conceived or heard
of and the idea of making a movie out of
that not adding a whole bunch of spice
not turning it into speed but in the
desert but actually doing a Desert Bus
movie is maybe the most boring concept
for a movie anyone has ever conceived
ever ever ever ever ever for eight hours
thank you William this just in guys
breaking news this question it's a trick
question
let's take your answer and flip it this
is what you're arguing for what would be
the best video game to turn into a movie
okay so you're gonna ride that bus okay
or you're taking leader suit Larry and
arguing take your arguments and spin
them into why your film is the best
here's the video game fight it out I was
the problem with video game movies
almost every video game movie we've ever
seen is a watered-down reenactment of a
previous movie okay that's what a lot of
video games are they take an experience
you've seen in a movie and they give you
an opportunity to live it out in real
life problem is once that movie gets
back onto the big screen say doom what
it was - aliens or the the street
fighter world combat movies as they were
- Enter the Dragon
they're just this tired rehash you have
never seen desert bus desert buses new
desert bus might actually push the genre
in an entirely new direction
hey now these video game movies are
alike this is an arthouse film oh my god
we get bail it's hard to direct this and
eat out a museum installation I've never
heard of such a thing the critics will
go wild Oscar nominations abound oh my
god
sight and sound is gonna put at the top
of their best movies ever Paul the most
daring thing ever created holy crap well
there's tons of art films that unfold in
real time there's a museum there's a
video installation that's 16 hours of a
bus in the desert it's Matthew Barneys I
haven't done a million billion it's a
brown bunny which is an incredibly slow
slog with bits a gala basically driving
a bus through the desert no one saw it
terrible movie it has the Leisure Suit
Larry this is a bear - this is a tried
and tested genre it's just a sex comedy
we've seen millions of them they're huge
everybody loves them this could be in
law along the lines of super bag along
the lines of American Pie leisure -
Larry is an exact character that fits
into that he's a lovable loser he's not
a sleaze he's a lovable loser
he's somebody the audience would
definitely cipher and they root for
there's no reason that the movie has to
be gross and weird like the game is you
make a clamor you make it 2018 you make
it fit to the culture of today you know
what here's the thing that video game
movies don't need as a genre they don't
need to look worse that's the problem
with it it's as terrible
genre the best movies ever had in the
video game genre are still not all-time
classics are there like Mortal Kombat
Silent Hill and Warcraft like they're
okay but like they're not like upper
echelon in their genre Leisure Suit
Larry we're just gonna add another sex
comedy to the mix at a time when people
are actually bringing up again hey our
video games having too much of an
influence on our kids we're gonna
announce that we're doing Leisure Suit
Larry that's gonna be great I look
forward to all of the protests and think
pieces we're gonna get about why we
should not be making this movie isn't
this the worst idea tons of sex comedies
come out they're not protesting people
love them bridesmaids you loser Larry
has a history of actually being just
pure I'll sexism as you're so silly
cheesy jokes is nothing offense how
offensive his Leisure Suit Larry when I
found out I was gonna do Leisure Suit
Larry I vowed to let him have the point
question I was just gonna say that is
the worst idea for a video game movie
ever that is the absolute worst thing
ever and before this became a trick
question I was just like I'm gonna lose
but then you can have wait hours in real
time on a bus I think you outdid
yourself alright gentlemen I'm gonna ask
each of you to cast your film and tell
us who the director of your film would
be take a moment think about it okay
time enough William Richard Linklater a
guy who proved that anything is possible
a guy who made a movie over the course
of what was it like 85 years later boy
12 years to make boy that was
exaggerating for comedic but thank you
we have a guy who actually has the
artistic clout to actually get people
into a theater they actually get people
checking this out and actually who is
who is the star the camera you are the
star you are desert bus isn't that the
most exciting thing ever think about the
t-shirts you're gonna sell afterwards
t-shirts that said I survived a desert
bus t-shirts that say I went on the
desert bus adventure it's gonna be like
et all over again I went to ET I was
desert bus that's an amazing miracle
think about all of the stories that we
have now that are just explosions and
loudness and nonsense here we have a
contemplative thoughtful movie that
actually just gives you the opportunity
to sit there and think and think about
what is unfolding in front of you that
is beauty all right lon
your director is Steven Soderbergh and
your star is john c reilly I mean
Hatcher's he's he's the guy he's we
understand him he's lonely he's kind of
a loser he's a little awkward but he's a
good guy and we root for him we want him
to find happiness we want him to bid to
be sweet and to meet the girl of his
dreams even though he's got a lot of
really bad sort of crazy ideas about the
world and Steven Soderbergh a guy who
can take a goofy genre comedy and really
invest it with a lot of heart and a lot
of soul and a lot of humanity we've seen
him do it many times he took the magic
microworld and made it soulful and
relatable and believable for people all
across the country he could do the same
with the world time wow what an
smackdown alright so this is a very
difficult choice - movies that I didn't
think I wanted before I probably still
don't want William you really started to
sell me on this being an arthouse film
that we have not seen the likes of and
it'll be an experience but then I wasn't
sure what I was watching as I was
picturing it in my head either but yes
the bus driving through the desert and
yeah listens to the right yeah I don't
feel like you expounded upon what we
have been thinking about would I be
dozing or what yeah I just can't see
that as a feature film but man when you
brought out john c reilly i am a sucker
for steve brule i love john c reilly and
yeah it would be we have so many sex
comedies it could it could be more
palatable you alluded to that that it
would be a little bit watered down
William I thought you rebutted nicely
with some of the stuff about video games
being divisive in the climate we live in
nowadays but lon you gave me a film that
seemed just like a more plausible actual
movie and I go point lon dan Moreau
quick factual correction as early as
fans of boyhood or red letter media
would tell you until 12 years to make
[Applause]
twelve years to be worth every yea did
Biddy I had me at the very top with them
with the art house thing and you know
that it's in a museum and it's revered
as art he had the first I would say one
third of this fight but Lon Lon closed
the deal for me
he had the casting he had the director
mhm he he had the tried and true genre
he sold me I'm gonna have to go for lon
as much as I admire Viviani he was
forced into the art house approach and I
figured they're not working in his favor
so I'm gonna go yeah he did the best he
had let's hear from Daniel Radford the
social media ambassador extraordinary
alright well the voice of the people
were 59% for a Leisure Suit Larry what
does that even mean they want Desert Bus
first of all Viviani I survived desert
bust first of all how dare you
personally as someone who was hit by a
bus I'm very offended
I lived on to become a social of media
ambassador the desert wasn't it was in
California we had a couple of castings
for Leisure Suit Larry at pan underscore
Grendel says I want to see Ryan
Reynolds's Leisure Suit Larry two
good-looking
yeah the point is he's like got a
receding hair and at you bakit events
definitely once how
thank you all so just one just one thing
I want to say at home the underscore 83
says Ecco the Dolphin hated that game as
a kid imagine how boring that would be
as a movie and once again how dare you
when he first came up with this question
the first game that was mentioned was
Ecco the Dolphin it's so weird it's so
good I will not take this Dreamcast
Lander man Danielle you being offended
by dolphins by buzz day they have your
number today they got me thank you for
breaking that down all right so it is to
one and it is time for the speed round
but first uh-huh
we've got a very exciting offering
coming up on screen junkies if you like
Pacific Rim and you like puppies this is
for you jte why don't you drop that
Prius listen up man this is real serious
business all right this is the fate of
the world all right as we know it the
only thing standing in front of the dog
apocalypse is us but doesn't matter
where you walked here from who believed
you were a good boy who didn't there are
dogs we remember as legends but they
didn't start out that way
they started out like pups this is our
time this is our chance to make a
difference this is our chance to run and
pee on grass puppy pilots do you
understand now you help me save the
world all of you you you and you let's
do this ready wow man got John boyega
holding puppies what more could you ask
for that is coming from screen junkies
coming up this Monday very exciting the
only way it looks like it could have
been better is if you had milli the dog
in there that's my adorable dog okay
time for the speed round
William is up two to one but it is
anybody's game we have four speed round
questions the first competitor to get
four answers awarded to them takes home
today's championship today's prize which
is bragging rights
[Music]
so you each get 20 seconds 22nd 2010
second rebuttal for each of you the
first person to answer gets to go first
will you have any questions I'm scared
oh you got this one any questions I'm
good to go yeah you got this okay
somebody's got this question number one
of the speed round oh and by the way
Danielle will now be judging with her
very own opinions cuz there's no time to
put a pole together for these yeah I'm
still gonna try to get in some of the
memes so make sure you get them in hot
and fast yeah BAM there you go
question numero uno you both worked at a
video store together man so crazy what
is the most pretentious movie somebody
could recommend to another person laugh
Oh
Fellini is eight and a half ago last
year at Marienbad okay so we have eight
and a half versus last year at Marienbad
William you spoke first whenever you're
ready ænima happens most pretentious
movie ever made eight and a half is
Fellini saying I'm the greatest artist
ever now look at everyone I've ever
slept with and how they're great because
they slept with me and then I made this
film it is nothing self-exalting shots
and scenes it is just how great this
artist is and frankly it's not his best
film time one last year at Marienbad
it's an experimental movie where a
couple is at a party and the man
continually tries to convince the woman
that they've met before even though she
does not believe that they have its
allegorical no one knows what it's
really trying to say probably because
it's not really trying to say anything
it's just a lot of very elegant sounding
French dialogue that sort of flying
around last year at Marienbad is
actually an incredibly exciting movie
about all these different stories
happening simultaneously things
happening and not happening
simultaneously it is a litmus test for
everyone who watches it do you think
they were together do you think they
never met ain't ain't a house full of
striking imagery it is a little
the diljit in that it's a character
study the directors making about
themselves but it's filled with
memorable imagery it sort of sums up a
lot of what Fellini was going through
and it's got a brilliantly part-time Wow
alright let's go to Danielle Radford oh
boy this is really these were great
arguments on both sides guys yeah these
are these these were fantastic arguments
on both sides I will say that I was more
drawn to babes argument about how
masturbatory not his word mine
masturbatory made half was for Fellini
and how was how great the artist was and
I liked that he talked about how last
minute last year at Marienbad was a
litmus test so I gotta give this one the
boobs but this was so close
BAM so it's Oh boobs and Lana I think
you sunk your own argument when you
called eight-and-a-half self-indulgent
and you were talking about the imagery
you started just you were describing
something very pretentious there so I
think you helped Williams argument as
you are trying to rebut his points so I
also side with William BAM
William gets the point three one Viviani
I need to take a moment everyone see
last year at Marienbad it's actually
thank you thank you for everybody it is
3-1 right now lawn needs this point to
continue the game if he doesn't get it
maybe Ani goes home a winner alright
question number two the speed around the
Infinity Ward's final trailer drops
tomorrow what would be the worst
possible reveal that would make you not
want to see the movie it's a crossover
with the DC films universe
oh geez this is actually really really
hard because I think they'd forgive
anything um everyone dies there you have
it okay
DC crossover everyone dies lawn you
spoke first 20 seconds on the clock for
lawn Harris Wow does nobody want DC's
struggling to keep alive franchise to
invade on the Marvel MCU which is firing
on all cylinders is the last thing we
need to try to integrate these seven or
eight characters nobody likes these long
boring backstories that nobody wants to
get into instead we've got this perfect
MCU is running like a well-oiled machine
everything's coming together this would
legitimately be the worst possible way
that they could handicap the story time
for the next 10 minutes everyone dies I
don't mean like half the universities
like infinity god I mean like literally
everyone dies and then Kevin Feige comes
up on the trailer and just says no
really we're done and we're just gonna
kill a movie it's over we're sorry we're
just gonna take your money
that's a terrible trailer that'll be the
worst right I'm just filling out my time
I think that you're the worst thing you
could possibly see in an MCU trailer
well that would actually be how to end
the franchise on how to make everybody
lose interest I actually think if you
killed everybody and you rebooted all
these guys just doing really exciting
there's an opportunity to bring in all
of this new blood reimagine how all
these characters are together and it's
the right time anyway as we're rolling
up the story I'm not saying we're gonna
bring them back I'm saying they're dead
and everything's over never making
Marvel movies again whereas I think
everyone kind of wants to see all these
superheroes fight each other that's kind
of the cold geek mentality even if it's
only one time you'd like to see BAM if I
Captain America time all right Wow both
would be very interesting to hear in the
trailer
tomorrow Dan Moreau what do you think
it's a double tiered thing number one I
think it is an incredibly the one thing
that keeps me from seeing things or at
least dampens my enthusiasm or is if
someone spoils it for me and that would
be the ultimate spoiler number one and
number two if they put out a trailer
with Captain America fighting next to
Superman I would go sleep on the street
to see that
even buy tickets like that anymore and I
would still do it even if it sucks it
sounds cool III gotta go I gotta go
video all right that's one Oh baby honey
Danielle uh yeah I I I really do want to
I want to see the two of them cross over
even with the problems that there are
and the same way that like we all were
like kind of over the spider-man
universe but whatever that's a different
argument but the idea that you're
watching the trailer and Kevin Figgy at
the end comes out and does a Ferris
Bueller like no it's over go home we're
not doing this anymore yeah that might
make me not want to see the movie
anymore if I was like was that just how
the movies gonna end with Kevin Feige
coming out and telling me to go home
so yeah man this is there so yeah I got
to go with boobs on this one Biebs takes
it bibs congratulations you are today's
movie fights winner man that was well
fought and I got a meet with Dan I'd be
like what guys all know that they would
be horrible you all know
bibs congrats go ahead and plug some
what's going on no one but I have to
podcasting listen to cancel too soon an
iTunes stitcher libsyn we reviewed
television series that lasted only one
season or less throughout the month of
March we're doing all shows about cops
with robot partners there were a lot of
them and they almost always failed
they're really really weird and it's a
lot of fun almost always what's an
example
it wasn't about it but so we pointed out
that that's an exception you got you got
a bunch of weird stuff in there call
2070 Condor future copped a bunch of
weird stuff also I have the critically
acclaimed podcast on the schmoes no
network where every week we review a
notoriously bad film as chosen by our
listeners and then we pair it with a
good movie to make the ultimate double
feature so you can hear that on the
schmoes no iTunes feeder in the sk+
youtube channel
very cool thanks bibs and well-fought
congratulations Vlad Harris you always
bring it always very entertaining a
little more Yeley today than I usually
should always entertaining go ahead and
tell us something that's going on what
do you have to do the rest no I get to
go see a ready player one the few days
looking forward to that very exciting
and the delightful dance dance squared
and anything to plug anything exciting
you get you were filled with exciting
announcements if somebody say I feel
like I've got one Dan Morel thank you
for bringing the facts and the fun
Daniel Radford um yeah just find me I'm
Daniel Radford on Twitter or keep doing
that thing where you're finding me on
instagram at danielle underscore Radford
help me get to 10k so I can start
plugging that diet tea or tooth stuff
for dresses or weird odor that yeah
to stuff TK so she can be an influencer
for clothes I just want to be out there
in my fashion Nova hell yeah universe
thanks Danielle thanks for holding it
down on the social media and please hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at Hal
Rudnick thank you so much for watching
and we'll see you next time Oh two weeks
in two weeks back in one week come to
WonderCon for some just honest trailer
and movie fight fun bye bye
you